okay let's get this night out let's
control d5 as soon as I do deep okay now
actually we have it's a being populated
right now on chess cube what this
opening is it's the English opening or
another way you can view it is a
reversed Sicilian right in this case
it's white that's moving the C pawn two
squares and black that's moving the King
pawn the epon two squares so this is a
more tame move I think it's usually
bishop before that gets played and I
think now my opponent does run the risk
of getting overrun in the center with
first this e3 advance and eventually d4
and once I establish a pawn on d4 what
do you do next once you have that pawn
on d4 in fact you could consider to duo
at that point C for D for duo what do
you do with it next how do you put that
space advantage to good use maybe d5
right inconvenience that Queen Knight
now my question to myself here is do I
play d4 or do I play 90 to first
my opponent cannot prevent me from
playing d4 it's one thing
ninety-two or just d4 right away
does it really matter do I want my
knight on f3 instead of e2 I don't think
so I'm not gonna I'm not gonna commit my
pawn just yet it cannot be prevented I
don't see a rush with doing it so I'm
just I'm not gonna do it just yet
maybe there's a reason with a reason for
playing something like d3 instead hmm
okay that mu Bishop moved a second time
so my opponent is having a change of
plan here are they really going to take
my knight there better be some
compensation if that's to occur give up
the bishop pair what type of
compensation can be seen all right what
should you have is compensation if
you're giving up the bishop hair
sometimes a leading development
sometimes structural damage to your
opponent I think those are two main ones
let's see
night here d4 maybe I should throw a
question that Bishop let's see what it
wants to do or maybe just first d3 to
stop this advance yeah I'm gonna do that
I'm gonna baby step this I don't want a
four to be played and I don't want this
pond to be locking down on these f3 and
D 3 squares allowing this pond to play
here successfully implies that this
night could then make use of a 5 let's
see what the bishop is gonna do is
you're gonna run back to f8 if he does
I'll just follow up I think with b4 and
Bishop b2 I may even want to play h3 ok
now Bishop pair and I'm not seeing what
the compensation is for giving up that
Bishop pair so now my attention turns to
this guy what can he do that will be
influential
I think getting it on this main diagonal
is best so that's why I'm playing b4
maybe down the line there's some
thoughts of b5 is it worthwhile to just
play Age 3 right here I'm gonna try it
maybe there's g4 later on maybe even f4
I'm kind of having some flashbacks to a
game that I played recently that I
posted to YouTube where I had a pawn
chain right here and the LightSquared
bishop got crunched I ended up not
winning but it was a good position at
one point and now maybe I'm regretting a
doing h3 maybe I should have expanded in
the Senate when I had the chance now
this is ready to be played maybe I'm
okay with it though let's go here is the
Queen gonna play their King eh - to
defend if this advance comes then I
could okay let's do it
I think I want to
be a pain somehow how can I be a pain
let me do this avoid the night exchange
the right here is a wonderful square
this this c5 square corresponds to what
the c-4 square again keep in mind this
is a in English the English opening or
again reverse Sicilian so on the white
side against an open Sicilian you really
have to be cautious of a black night
getting to see for if this is a reverse
Sicilian it's now c5 that black would
then be needing to watch out for and
that's what I'm ready to do this night
right here pouncing on that c5 square is
just devastating
if b6 cannot be played successfully I
think now this is just this is very
difficult now for black this night
getting to that square he's just doing
so much this I know how difficult it is
to deal with the night on c5 because
I've had to struggle myself in positions
like these and allow a knight I had to
see I'd actually feel how it was to have
a knight just sit on that square okay so
he's gone he's off the board but notice
this light square diagonal very weak
very very weak right here and I think
there's got to be some there's got to be
some wind right here
it's pile up on this night Queen b3 hit
this Knight a second time I think that
does the trick maybe Queen here is
unprotected there's no tricky Knight
moves or anything are they're not really
seeing it if there are so how Queen b3
rook c1 just double up on the C file as
my plan right here my bishops are
working well from afar let's do this
am I missing anything I should probably
go quicker one-minute warning
Bishop hare Bishop area bishop pair
pile-up on this night I think it's a
very clear plan at this point
maybe my king wants to get to eat too
very soon this is a one poem that I'll
likely be needing to watch over is on a
half-open file we're evening out here
with time now what less than 50
it's a tricky tricky nights but I'm
covering the support points the Knights
don't really have support points do they
I think now now let's just do this pawn
push there's got to be something better
maybe Queen here just push just push
make forceful moves be practical forcing
moves fast I really don't I don't want
to move my a pond because it gives this
night a square so he's done moving I
think or maybe I'm okay with allowing
that to come about let's see I could
take here a bunch of times and then grab
this
let's just double double those rooks
double on the C file maybe I will Stu do
maybe I will still play this a four move
no time though 15 seconds 12 piling up
if this advance comes this Bishop can
see more of the position anything okay
there in blitz mode superfast blitz mode
here bullet mode now the night is
falling let's just do it with this the
Queen's come off the board this line no
time okay all right good game let's go
back clearly in the opening there's
gonna be an improvement and I use the
word clearly because of this Bishop
moving twice east 7b for initially to b4
I think is there gonna be the move in
this position so that I can't get my
knight here in time to defend this I
think I think there's a I think there's
a line that runs in this case instead of
Bishop e7 Bishop b4 and if I do
III to capture the night before I get my
Knight to e2 to have them connected so
looking to Bishop b4 instead of East 7
to think about is getting in this d5
advance so if you really want to get d5
in then what should you be doing you
should be developing your King Knight
first make moves that are going to
facilitate this advance Knight f6 g3 is
getting ready to play Bishop g2 and just
prevent d5 all together so it becomes
very timely so Knight f6 if g3 then get
in d5 takes takes and after Bishop g2 I
believe the move is to just retreat meet
the threat on d5 and that retreat move
allows the Queen to
job for this d4 advance just like just
like in the what am I saying it just
like on the black side in an open
Sicilian the d5 move is a liberating
move since this is a reverse Sicilian
the corresponding squared d4 is going to
be a liberating move so be aware of this
potential strike that's why with this
line Knight f6 g3 d5 captures captures
after Bishop g2 there is that Knight
retreat so that the Queen from that line
that I was just running with is then
watching out for the d4 square okay um
good game let me well is there anything
more that's that's the main thing
because there's no compensation right
now for giving up that Bishop may be
better is to run away but this is still
very good for white a big space
advantage your Knights don't really have
good homes to be going with they're
developed classically but they're kind
of frozen and you don't have a pawn
break that's really going to be helpful
to the rest of your pieces so this is
trouble I think no matter how you slice
it if you go back to f8 you have B for
maybe B 5 things are much more smooth
for the white side okay